In the US, acting US ambassador to the UN...
...reiterated Secretary of State Mike Pompeo's assertion...
...that Iran was behind the attacks after the US Navy-released video...
...showing the ships that were attacked in the Gulf of Oman.
In Hong Kong, hundreds of Hong Kong women held a rally...
...to oppose the extradition bill and the police crackdown...
...against young demonstrators early this week.
More than 1,000 people joined a peaceful "mother's protest."
In Kyrgyzstan, Iranian President Hassan Rouhani...
...arrived at the 19th Shanghai Cooperation Organization summit in the capital, Bishkek,...
...and said the United States presents a serious threat to global and regional stability...
...as tensions soar in the Gulf.
In New Zealand, Brenton Tarrant,...
...the accused gunman in the New Zealand mosque mass shootings three months ago,...
...pleaded not guilty to all charges.
Finally, women across Switzerland left their workplaces, burned bras and blocked traffic...
...in a day of demonstrations to demand fairer pay, equality...
...and an end to sexual harassment and violence.
These were the first such protests in the nation in 28 years.